microsoft have been teasing a bunch of
different things that are on their way
for halo 5 guardians including next
month's introduction of forge tools and
now a new dlc entertainment and tech
site design and trend spotted a super
short video at the end of this week
taylor 5 live stream which teasers dlc
that looks to be arriving in december
from the look of it players will have
new weapons weapon skins and oma as well
as what appears to be a forge map set in
face if you're keen to really do some
damage you'll be happy to hear that one
of the new weapons looks awfully similar
to the m41 rocket launcher other items
from the clip include the mark for
helmet as well as some sweet black and
gold weapons the first major update for
halo 5 called battle of shadow in line
launched this week it added the big team
battle mode for new maps and a ton of
new rack packs it was the first in a
bunch of free updates at 343 have
planned for the lifespan of halo 5
Guardians let me know what you want to
see is future halo 5 updates down in
that comment box and stay tuned to
GameSpot's for all the latest